this ancient city was once the  cosmopolitan Center for the kingdom of  Pugin the first Kingdom to unify the  region's that created Burma  [Music]  the bargain archeological zone is an  ancient city located in central Myanmar  it is known for being covered in  incredibly ornate temples which stand  out of the sweeping green Plains and  lush vegetation these temples were built  by the kings of began between 10:57 and  1287 there were originally around 10,000  however today just over 2,000 remain in  varying states of repair the others have  been lost due to Mongol invasions and in  more recent times earthquakes the  remaining temples are maintained and are  constantly undergoing restoration to  keep them intact for future generations  to enjoy  [Music]